The Hulk vs. Wolverine in the MCU
something that we have all been waiting
for for a super super long time what's
up everyone it's Warren and I am just
super stoked to be doing this video it
has been reported that a Hulk vs.
Wolverine movie is going to be headed to
the MCU and not just a normal Hulk vs.
Wolverine but an immortal Hulk and the
introduction of Alpha Flight so we have
a ton of things to talk about today with
Hulk vs. Wolverine including whether or
not Hugh Jackman could come back to
reprise his role of Wolverine for just
one film because nothing would make a
Hulk vs. Wolverine film better than if
Hugh Jackman returned to play Wolverine
so we're gonna break down everything in
this video quick reminder if you'd like
a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain I'm
picking a winner real soon at 500,000
subscribers
Wolverine vs. the Hulk is one of the
most epic stories that has been done a
few times in the comics they have always
been some of the greatest events and
have been widely loved by the fans and
after Avengers in game a lot of people
have been wondering what exactly is
going to happen with the Hulk because a
lot of people weren't exactly too
thrilled with his story Argan Avengers
in game because he didn't really do much
yes he performed the snap and brought
everybody back but besides that he
didn't really do much a lot of people
were waiting for him to Hulk out but he
remained a professor helped the whole
entire time but everybody would
definitely be satisfied watching him
take on Wolverine finally bringing the
ultimate comic Clash to the big screen
so there was a report of Wolverine
versus the Hulk coming to the MCU on the
big screen a few days ago and there was
also a new one today so let's start with
the original report so shout out to
Mikey Sutton who originally reported
this news Mikey has a very excellent
track record with leaks he reported the
Fox Disney deal in 2015 a year before it
was announced he reported Spider Man
heading into the MCU into Civil War
before it was announced which of course
ended up being true he reported that
Robert Pattinson was one of the
frontrunners to play Batman which
of course is official now and he's
offered a lot of news on the sony disney
deal recently so he has a very excellent
track record and he has recently come
out and reported that Marvel is making a
Wolverine versus the Hulk movie and yes
this movie is apparently supposed to
take place in the MCU so this was the
original report and something that is
definitely worth noting in this report
is that it is going to be a Wolverine
vs. Hulk movie not Hulk vs. Wolverine
and there's a very specific reason for
that Universal owns the distribution
rights for the Hulk this is why there
hasn't been a solo Hulk film since 2008
Marvel and Disney cannot make a solo
Hulk film however they can have the Hulk
appear in other group movies that's why
he's in Avengers infinity war avengers
ingame thor ragnarok because it's not
technically a Hulk movie so as long as
he's not the main character it's fine
which is why this film is going to be a
Wolverine Wolverine being first versus
the Hulk right now there's actually a
bit of a debate whether or not you can
put the Hulk's name in the title of the
movie but as of right now we're calling
it Wolverine versus the Hulk but this is
essentially going to be a Hulk story
much like thor ragnarok that movie was a
locked about the Hulk it was really
Planet Hulk they just couldn't call it
Planet Hulk because technically they
don't own the rights to do that so
instead what we got was thor ragnarok
which was part hulk part Thor but still
a story about the Hulk which is what
this Wolverine versus the Hulk is going
to be it's going to be a hope story
while also introducing Wolverine and the
x-men if they're not already introduced
by then into the MCU so this was Mikey's
first report that Marvel is going to be
making a Wolverine verse The Hulk movie
in the MCU but then he came out with a
second report and in this report we
learned more about what the story is
going to be about in this Wolverine vs.
Hulk film and to start off the Hulk that
is going to be in Wolverine versus the
Hulk is going to be based off of a
mortal Hulk from the comics and immortal
Hulk is apparently going to go to Canada
on a mission to retrieve Wolverine
however when he gets there he is going
to run into alpha flight that's right
the Wolverine versus the Hulk movie is
supposed to introduce alpha flight into
the MCU so
apparently the Hulk is going to be
searching for Wolverine and we'll run
into alpha flight alpha flight is
they're looking for Wolverine as well
and apparently Alpha Flight thinks that
they won't really get along with the
Hulk so well this of course leads to a
big battle so this movie is supposed to
introduce Weapon X or Wolverine into the
MCU this is kind of what happened in the
comics but of course obviously the MCU
is going to do their own twist to it but
it doesn't really come as that big of a
surprise that Marvel is going to adapt
one of the biggest comic events of all
time to a big screen movie in the MCU
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios is a comic historian he knows
how big the event of the Hulk vs.
Wolverine is and he knows how big
avengers endgame was so he knows that
eventually he's going to have to figure
out a way to top Avengers endgame and
this is the perfect way to do it and it
also solves some pretty big problems
that Marvel has right now one of those
problems is Professor Hulk again fans
really didn't like professor Hulk they
wanted to see Hulk smash
so now Marvel's problem is how to get
away from professor Hulk after the story
arc of avengers endgame well if you know
anything about the comics and about the
Hulk vs. Wolverine events you know that
there's one person who can get under the
Hulk skin more than anybody and make him
explode with rage and that is of course
Wolverine professor Hulk was super tame
in Avengers end game when he was back in
time in 2012 in New York and he saw his
former self smashing he was a little
embarrassed and when they told him to
smash a few things along the way to his
mission he couldn't really Hulk out
professor Hulk is much more tame than a
normal Hulk but perhaps a Wolverine
could do the job to make the Hulk lose
it and that's what it's looking like
we're going to see here because there is
no Wolverine versus professor Hulk you
all saw professor Hulk in Avengers end
game there's no way that he's taking on
Wolverine Wolverine beats him hands down
but if Wolverine can bring out the true
Hulk and a version of the mortal Hulk
then we have a huge fight and that's
what we're most likely going to see in
this story so this movie will solve the
professor Hulk problem but another thing
that it solves is how to introduce
Wolverine into the MCU the Fox deal has
been done for a while
Disney officially owns the rights to use
the x-men in the MCU and at San Diego
comic-con Kevin Feige dropped mutants I
didn't even have time to talk about the
Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
[Applause]
but all that smells good rumor and
you've heard about rumors so now the
biggest question is how is Marvel going
to introduce mutants into the MCU but
more importantly how is Marvel going to
introduce Wolverine into the MCU
because everybody loves Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine a lot of fans have a hard time
thinking of Wolverine being played by
anybody else
after all Hugh Jackman has played
Wolverine for over 15 years so how
exactly do you introduce Wolverine in
the MCU
well it certainly wouldn't hurt to do it
in a massive event such as Wolverine
versus the Hulk because even if people
aren't excited that we have a new
Wolverine that isn't Hugh Jackman they
will definitely be excited about a Hulk
vs. Wolverine movie but right now there
is talk that Hugh Jackman could possibly
make a return to play his character of
Wolverine now this is purely speculation
at this point this is not a report it is
not confirmed at all it's just people
speculating that perhaps he could come
back based on some things that he said
in the past at one point in time Hugh
Jackman said that he could possibly
return to play the character if that
character was in the MCU now it's been
some time since he said this and since
he has come out and said that he has
also come out and said that he is
officially done playing Wolverine he has
retired from the role so don't count on
Hugh Jackman returning to reprise his
role of Wolverine
fortunately Marvel has plenty of time to
decide who exactly they want to play
Wolverine
according to Mikey Sutton's report this
Wolverine vs. the Hulk movie will not be
made for another four to five years
which makes sense and goes along right
with what Kevin Feige said when he
mentioned that casting for the x-men
won't even start for at least another
few years this gives them plenty of time
to pick the perfect person to play
Wolverine in the MCU for the next 10 to
15 years it also gives them time to cast
the other x-men and Alpha Flight as well
and it gives them time to make sure that
they do these movies right
many people have severely disliked the
x-men movies that Fox has produced over
the past few years and Marvel is very
very well aware of that and they're
going to make sure they can do
everything they possibly can to make
very good x-men movies for everybody to
watch and knowing Marvel and based off
everything that they have produced over
the
eleven years they're going to do it so
we still have to wait a little bit
longer but it appears that a Wolverine
versus the Hulk movie is going to be
coming to the MCU it's important to note
that this is not confirmed but again
Mikey Sutton has an incredible track
record of being right about things
happening in the MCU so it does seem
like we're finally going to get the
battle that we've all been waiting to
see on the big screen so be sure to let
me know what you think about this be
sure to let me know how excited you are
to finally see the Hulk go up against
Wolverine and right now let me know who
you think would be perfect to play
Wolverine in the MCU it's hard to think
of anybody playing Wolverine but Hugh
Jackman but let me know who your second
pick would be and a reminder about my
giveaway be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking a winner
at 500,000 subscribers and the winner
will get to choose one also be sure to
check out my new personal channel
culture captains as a comedy based
channel and would love it if you all
went over and subscribed don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof